well have you ever stayed in an airbnb
maybe verbo well they're not legal in
unincorporated clark county but that is
changing county commissioners want your
feedback crafting short-term rental
regulations assembly bill 636 mandates
the county and cities of las vegas
henderson and north las vegas adopt
ordinances to comply the bill requires
the county to create and implement rules
regarding noise with possible quiet
hours or even limits on amplified sound
the idea is to deter those so-called
party houses other areas of concern
though include distance between rentals
maximum occupancy as well as hoa consent
there's some mixed opinions about
short-term rentals in our community uh
obviously for people that
are renting out their house uh they've
got strong opinions and want the rules
as flexible as possible so they can
continue to get some extra income
uh other people obviously you know have
issues with short-term rentals rentals
coming into their communities so they
want strict regulation
certainly hot button issue that meeting
happening at clark county government
center 5 30 this evening and if you
can't attend in person you can tune in
on facebook